[Music]
welcome to the iron lords podcast
hello everyone and welcome to the
ireland podcast first look video of a
game called tactical combat department
from the developer lucas h
now
um i wanted to tell you all about it
because i had a little bit of time
playing it and i thought it was a very
interesting game i have one of the maps
here shown uh as i'm playing through it
and you can hear me talking talking
about as we're going through but uh one
of the things i wanted to talk to you
guys about was
this game is a very very interesting
game and has a lot of potential to grow
now the reason why i'm saying it's got a
lot of potential to growth was
coming from
my background of turn-based strategy
games uh i mean i'm talking about like
xcom series and uh you know warsaw back
in the day and you know um shining force
and things like that i've played a lot
of turn-based strategy games it's
probably one of my favorite uh type of
game genres and
i think this game what it brings is a
huge realism to the world of actual
turn-based strategies and how they can
make it better um i think that the the
combat was was a little unique uh i
think it was it could have been uh you
know a little bit better played off but
i think that from the way that they're
working with and and you know it being a
nourish developer i think that you know
it has you know great potential for that
uh the music was very low-key somber uh
the environments were very filled um i
will say that the
perspectives of the in the viewing of
the the maps were from
the way the people were sitting were
great
um i loved the
the whole
uh assault portion of that and tactical
portion of that uh and what i mean by
that is
when you're going into uh this building
um
when you go into the building
you have to kind of look around and see
what's going on
and seeing who's around the building
clear out the outside make sure there's
no one outside the building and then go
inside
but there was a couple of times where we
actually got shot at and
that was because there are people inside
the building that were able to see us
outside and then they ended up going
after us so we had to kind of know that
watch it and we're like oh crap we got
to make sure we uh i'll cover this or do
that or stand close to the wall here so
we don't get hit there and and so on and
so forth and it kind of worked out not
too bad
now
um
the
sometimes the keys got a little wonky
for me
uh the guns um sometimes were a little
glitchy
when uh when i was trying to figure out
like what weapons did what
um but all in all i i kind of thought it
had it had a lot of potential and i
think that it could be really really
good
i do like how the the guns you know when
when you end up playing them you had the
uh the m4 which had had a decent range
and uh
decent you know clip size uh but it was
heavier just like the uh chess piece
uh and then the same thing going for the
um the shotgun uh i never had to
use deadly force
on anyone
um
actually that's a lie i used i had to sh
one person got shot in like an auto
retaliation kind of like an instant
overwatch that i even put on uh but
it actually it worked out pretty well
because it kind of stunned the person so
it worked out pretty cool uh i would
definitely say that this is one of those
games um if you got a like a bunch of
time in your hands and you know you're
you want to just kind of zone out and
play it uh pick it up uh i think that
you know it's it has a lot of potential
to it
and uh it has a lot of great things that
could quite possibly could happen uh
with the teams i think that having a
team of only five people uh which is
uh
kind of uh
shortens the amount of people you can
have on the map
but it can also give you a huge amount
of potential of
where people could be and and how you
can end up defending them and and what's
going on and by the way the looking
underneath the doors
uh for where the people are uh was was
great um seeing if you can find and
every single time they moved they would
go to another place that was really cool
so you know it was good it had a lot of
potential and i liked it so uh
definitely go ahead and uh you know
check it out when you get some time uh
this is pete again uh sneldo uh i am on
twitch uh five days a week monday to
friday on sneldo.tv uh if you ever
wanted to come check us out i am there
uh make sure if you have any comments or
anything like that please post them
below uh i greatly appreciate it thank
you again everybody and have a fantastic
rest of your day everybody thanks bye
got the pepper spraying
you know listen you get the spray
this suspect is a keyword
it's a bathroom
um
pretty sure he has enough apd let's get
in front of her door kick it flash
dragon if he needs to
because the flashbang has a startle
so they're like
don't usually shoot
so let's get him over here
about one
door obviously those aren't doors you
can see through
let's you guys go through two doors one
going through another door
oh great
he doesn't have enough points for
flashbang
this is four
um
suspect secured and ready for transport
noted do not have him do
door bang duty
door is locked
put your hands up
um
this suspect is a keyword
i love it when they move when you don't
want them to move because they're
looking as weird
that was
hey boys
dude that's what he did when he opened
the doors okay boys
hey jenny are you doing good video
i will be very very shortly
that's actually closer
i'll probably be playing within the next
uh
a little bit here
wait to do anything for that
you
i'm kind of chill there
did
flashbang
poof
like how did he disappeared
[Music]
you